board. And here we go. Welcome to another Zoom call everyone. Just a reminder to check
the member site for the announcements like last week's announcement that we were not able to
have a Zoom call. Also another reminder if you're going to do an educational coaching call, a call
with me, you can pay for an online, you have to fill out that coaching call request for
same thing with. There's a cheek swab request form that you have to fill out. So it's not
the people that regularly are on this call that make that mistake, but a lot of people that
may not listen to the calls or something that they don't have to remind them. So make sure that
the forms are filled out. Also reminder the courses are available for everybody. So you're a full
member, you have availability of all the courses, go to that and of course the blogs. The big news is
the RIF update. We've recommended for most people just to stay with the RIF program you're running
with version 6.0. Some people who have been with us longer and are still running a five-point
program that really needs to be updated. Updating your computer and such all the information
and the videos and such are on the member site. So look at the member site for information
whether you should update it. Everybody's missed the deadline now to update your F117. If you
started with us in the last four years you have it F122, but before that you might have it F117
and you had that opportunity to update it. We sent out an email and sorted true RIF and so that
would close down. Okay let's get to the questions. By one breast is being completely eaten away by
the cancer slowly but surely. Is that normal? Well it's never normal. Is it common? Yes it's common.
So as the cancer is continuing to grow it can be basically kind of devouring the rest of the
breast tissue. That's actually a better scenario than the two were just getting larger and larger
and larger. So that's when the cancer is continuing to grow and the breast is getting kind of eaten
away that's actually a better scenario than the scenario of the breast, the two were getting larger
and larger and larger. We've seen plenty of that over the years. That is a little scarier. It
doesn't always have this best outcome. You've seen this happen with other women with breast cancer
and their breast seems the tissue seems to just kind of get eaten away and the things stop. So
you know you're already doing everything you can. I know you've recommended you talk to your
oncologist again. It seems like they're not really giving you any solutions at all. I
surgery really isn't probably even offered to you at this time. So I don't know that I would change
anything. I know this person that I think we have just talked recently so I don't think there's
anything else to change. I was recently reviewing my genetic summary. Near the beginning
under the section Peter's bolded caffeine it says to avoid or limit caffeine.
Texas bolded but not highlighted. Okay so this is the genetic summary. So those of you that have
started with us in the last couple of years you know that you receive a full genetic report that
you receive a genetic summary and then you receive a genetic action steps. So in the genetic summary
the only thing you need to pay attention to is the highlighted pieces. If it's not highlighted
you don't need to pay attention to it. It wasn't an issue with your genes. Later in this section
on tumor suppressor genes the HIF1A it mentions that caffeine is a possible intervention. What should I
make of this? Also if that wasn't highlighted you could ignore both those things. If it was highlighted
then caffeine. So just so you know with with HIF1A genes caffeine can help that gene work better.
So that's another reason why I have told all of you that drinking a little coffee is okay. I know
there's natural paths out there and natural doctors that you know curse coffee and think coffee is
just this evil beast that's destroyed our health. That's not me. I don't believe that.
If you look at any of the latest done bias studies it actually shows that coffee can be
beneficial for a lot of things. However caffeine itself if you have the genes of that first page
in that summary I don't remember the gene it is that gene family. If you don't and I highlighted
that then caffeine needs to be watched a little closer. So if you have a specific gene defect
you actually detox coffin quite well. I used to tell people before that gene was identified
you could tell if a person detox detoxifies caffeine well as if they drink coffee and they have
the uridate. So yeah I love coffee. But yeah typically if I drink a couple cups of coffee I have to
go pee. Well that's a good thing. You're getting rid of it. Over the years of me practicing over the
last 35 plus years I've had people I remember this one guy this is not a cancer patient decades ago
you drink seven pots of coffee a day. That cups pots of coffee a day. This guy was a blue collar
worker. He's the funniest guy in the world. I just loved this guy. He had rheumatoid arthritis
and he had a serious coffee addiction. But I asked him this are you what are you going to the
bathroom all day? No coffee doesn't make him pee at all. Well caffeine was an issue with his rheumatoid
arthritis. He had a addiction to caffeine and caffeine would stimulate you know more damage to his
joint capsule cell. So we had to get him to cut way back on his caffeine and just cutting back on his
caffeine. There's no way we were going to eliminate it in his life. He just wasn't willing to do that
but it made a big difference in his symptoms. So I don't think everybody should be drinking
you know a ton of caffeine every day but a little bit of caffeine can actually be beneficial
for the HIF1 agent. So that's almost the same about that. So read the instructions in the top of
your genetic summary it says to the really you're only looking at the highlighted genes.
The highlighted genes are the ones that you have issues with nothing else. I'm getting ready to
submit a second cheek swab for supplement recommendations. How does one know what it might be a good time
to do a right update? But almost a year but faithfully using it but doing well but my PSA is recently
going on. So it depends on the cancer. So for prostate cancer really the only time you need to do
a right update for prostate cancer is if there's metastasis. So if there's no metastasis with
prostate cancer. With other cancers it depends if the person's getting worse it's good to check that
right update. They don't check and see if you need a right update if you don't they don't do it.
So a lot of you send in your cheek swab forms and you check general recommendations. You might make
some notes and you might you might check check right update too and you don't need a right update.
So we don't I don't charge you for a right update. So you could check that and I'll check
I don't most likely the answers no you won't need it. I don't glad they check and see.
What do you think of the gallery test? So I'm very familiar with the gallery test.
I've had the rap contact the multiple times I met with the rap one time.
The gallery test doesn't interest me at all unless the person does not know if they have cancer
and they want a good cancer screening test to find out if they have a high probability of cancer.
The gallery test does not you cannot tell a person via the results of the gallery test that they
definitively have cancer but you can tell a person that there's a really good chance that you have
cancer you need to go and get further investigation. So for a person that has already been diagnosed with
cancer already knows the have cancer already has been through treatment of cancer to be the gallery
test is absolutely zero value. So really the gallery test shines with people who hey I don't want
to go to a doctor to find out I have cancer I have this mess in my breast or whatever I don't feel
good I don't I don't I just feel like in my doctor something wrong and you want a screening test
well then the gallery test can be a good example there's other tests like this as well
the using the same technology is the colo the colo guard test but you that one you have to go to a
medical doctor and get it prescribed but that and that one only tests for colo rectal cancer it's
not this it uses the same technology as the IVG test for those of you who remember back four
years ago when the IVG test was available uses DNA recombinant technology so it's a valuable test but
if it does not give you a score like the IVG test gave you that's what made the IVG test so unique
the gallery test does not do that so as far as grading your cancer as far as knowing if you're
getting better or worse etc there's to be there's for some of the originals have cancer this is
zero value so that I explain that to the rap doesn't we never went any further because it's just to make
any sense at all to different patients I have the opportunity to get folded in a therapy locally
funds allowing how often and how many sessions is reasonably for me to for my current condition
both are expensive I was going to do the gallery because of my unexplained elevated AFP
I would not say that the gallery is going to give you the information that you want for that
but then thought why not do the photodynamic therapy instead at least once so understand photodynamic
therapy that is offered I would investigate what tools that they're using what equipment that they're
using if it is true photodynamic therapy then I would say if you have the opportunity one or the other I
would do that just you know we've talked about this I think this question about photodynamic therapy came up
oh about six eight months ago there's no
patented on that term so photodynamic therapy means light therapy so there are laser companies that
are selling laser lasers as photodynamic therapy I know that true photodynamic therapy does use lasers
that's why it's called photodynamic therapy but it uses a drug a chemical and it's very specific
to the cancer and it's pinpointed it's it's it's more elaborate technology than just a you know
level one two three or four laser so you I would investigate that but for sure I would choose a therapy
over the test I'm out of water pill small dosage which is not helping very much doctor is concerned
about electrolytes I have a recipe for one fourth of both cream of tartar and heavily in salt with warm
water I know salt is the best with thyroid issues can you give me any suggestions so if you want
suggestions to increase electrolytes so electrolytes are minerals so and you so if you want to increase
electrolytes and typically when you're talking about electrolytes in your body you're talking a lot
about sodium chloride and potassium so again how do you increase those it is with salt so it is using
salt so there's products on the market that are for electrolytes what do they have it basically have salt
if your purpose is just to increase those levels then using salt in a form of heavily in salt may be
appropriate you got to look at your blood test out and see what your low one so well no and not
low on potassium nor my low on sodium chloride it's not and it's not I mean if those if sodium
chloride are low then just taking salt is going to increase them if if if not then you don't need to
do that so look at a blood test in but I don't see anything wrong with doing that and I don't see
that hard made your thyroid gland if you're low on sodium chloride you do need more salt my understanding
is that for individuals doing radio chemo therapy okay we already this person and I had a
conversation so we're going to skip that question is there something safer than baby aspirin
to take so if you're as a what's your why you're taking this do you test for this with the cheek
I can if you ask specifically for it if you're asking something to help prevent blood clots so
can there are I know there's alternative perspectives on using aspirin and using baby aspirin which is
I think 88 milligrams of acetyl cell acid to help with clotting I don't think even from an
alternative perspective I know there's you know some studies that have come out that I can't damage
your heart I can damage the blood vessels taking it on a long-term basis what they used to I think
they still may recommend taking a baby aspirin you know every single day for people over a certain age
I don't know if that is even you know recommendation anymore I do think that with some people
yes it did cause cardiovascular damage taking it on a long-term basis but taking it for a
shorter basis because there's a potential clot formation I don't see anything wrong with that
is there other things that you could do to help prevent clot formation
yes things garlic is probably your number one thing to as a blood thinner from a nutritional perspective
and then using um lumbarochitis and nanochitis those are two enzymes that can be very beneficial
those are in the both the product called clear tox and the product called clear circulation
the clear circulation has more things for blood vessels in it but the clear tox has more things to
help detox it was mainly put together to help detox the ill effects of the COVID vaccine or the DNA vaccines
um but clear circulation might be another thing to think about too and like I said um garlic
I continued to experience vaginal dryness which is worsening to the point that I dread
intimacy I think it is called vaginal atrophy I could try using a cream suggested by my thyroid doctor
which contains a compounded vitamin A and E and helioronic acid and with a tiny bit of testosterone
would this be safe given by diagnosis of breast cancer what are my options so from an alternative
perspective vaginal dryness or vaginal atrophy typically the recommendation would be bioidentical
testosterone with a testosterone cream um it uh so is that a negative for breast cancer um
the answer is um yes and no so that there's a possibility that excess testosterone
will store in your fat cells and then through a process of a robotization will break down into the
quote unquote bad estrogen that could be an issue however that could be that could be uh managed
and monitored so um there's also evidence that using testosterone for uh with people with
breast cancer um can actually have great beneficial um attributes so I would say absolutely
go ahead with trying this cream I would try to cream first because that's simple before you try
to get into compounded uh testosterone um bioidenticals I would go for this I would for sure do this yes
at 850 milliliters taken off uh by long on friday four weeks before this they took off 500
millimeters a milliliters doctor says 15% of patients have a deba with kick right kebopill she left
be on it but is getting very uncomfortable just can't keep the fluid under control going to
occupational and physical therapy both two times a week I have lots of indigestion when taking
supplements this just started since the radiation of my 11th rib unless it is the adema in my body any
suggestions so the fluid in your lungs I don't think is from uh inflammation in your body I think
that's a sighties from the cancer you do want to monitor um the amount of fluid production over time
so the rate of fluid production so if you're going in every four weeks and they're taking off
500 milliliters then 850 milliliters then the next time it's 1250 milliliters that's a concern
so that's a red flag that there's an increase in the production of a sighties now there's other
ideas about this too so some people will say well that could happen if the cancer is dying off
and certainly being on a kebopill that could be a possibility so you do want to measure
that side of the increase in fluid uh a sighties with other signs and other symptoms as well just
like you know judge anything by just one test but if there's an increase in a sighties then that
is got to be a concern at least to be investigated I've been taking them with warm water
supplements wise sometimes that helps and other times it just doesn't matter I suppose it could be
from the kebopill certainly that kebopill can cause nausea can cause stomach upset I don't know what
that kebopill does to your HCl production so I would first thing I would say is maybe take make sure you're
taking your supplements with food and that you're taking uh some HCl or digest time type thing
with HCl at it with with that with that wheel to see if that helps too because if you have a decrease in
hydrochloric acid production in your stomach anything getting into your stomach especially the cap
capsule is going to irritate your stomach as you're not breaking that down quickly so look at that as well
the vitamin D level was tested last December and was found to be in the low 40s I started taking
one 80k avail almost every day last December it was retested again just recently and it's still in the
low 40s no improvement so 80k avail has 5,000 iUs of vitamin D in it per capsule if I remember correctly
um so friend of mine suggested that I switch to a liquid version of vitamin D that might absorb
it better in your thoughts I don't think you're going to absorb it better because you're actually
taking a gel cap it breaks out into a liquid immediately too so it's not that I think it's the dosage
so I think you eat so I um don't know what your uh vdr gene looks like that's your vitamin D receptor gene
picture looks like I'd have to pull up your genetic profile again if a person has defects on
their vdr genes um they have a much more difficult time um uh utilizing an absorbing vitamin D
if again if your HCl production hydrochloric acid production in your stomach is low
you're going to have a difficult time absorbing any supplements number three if your gallbladder
is cluperized at all either gallstones I have my gallbladder removed or I don't even know then I have
gallstones I have sluggish gallbladder whatever um you're going to have a difficult time absorbing
the fat soluble vitamins so if you have low vitamin D levels and you're taking vitamin D
you can't get the vitamin D levels up those are some of the things you need to look at what
I'll buy vitamin D receptors genetically look like if they have color profiles you have defects
either a single or especially a double allele defect on your vdr gene then you have to just
increase the dosage number two do I have a decrease hydrochloric acid production and each
grease had to chloric acid and is that causing a bowel absorption so it could be a bowel absorption issue
number three do I have gallbladder issues and a decrease in bile production bile is what you
need to absorb fat and break down the fats the A the vitamin A the vitamin D the vitamin K uh and
the vitamin E are all fat soluble vitamins it need bile in order for you to be able to utilize
them correctly and to get proper absorption so um those are the things that you want to look at
that's why I like that clear balance um sorry sorry sorry so I like the clear digest the digest
enzyme that we have private labeled as cutters clinic clear digest because it has just tell a
dust of this just today I think because it has HCl in it it has a good balance of enzymes for a breakdown
of of proteins and carbohydrates and fats and it has ox bile it's the only digest the enzyme that
I've seen there's probably others on the market that have all three of those things you need HCl
in order to digest food in your stomach otherwise that's going to go into your um into your
duodenum only partially digested and you're totally totally sent yourself on for HCl in infections
you need digestive enzymes to take pressure off your your pain-creas to help your digest
anything in your food and then uh how many people have sluggish gallbladders I mean lots um so
adding that ox bile is certainly a huge help for a lot of people so if you even you know people that
have no so a person has no gallbladder because they're gallbladder removed then you definitely you
can go right to that and you need more than what's in the clear digest you need ox bile so get an
ox bile supplement we have them in the store that effect I think we have um several that are
near expiration date that I'll throw I know who asked this question I think it's them
them and I will throw a bottle of that in your um dex order um I want to remind Megan so I
don't forget to remind her um because taking just taking one of those with your supplements could be
the solution and you don't even need to increase the amount of vitamin that you're taking
not sure if you're able to answer this my oncologist has me on pit crate 200 milligrams I'm
heavy lots of the demon uh she put me uh increased water pill we asked if she would consider
lowering the chemo dose because it seems to be working but maybe a little lower dose would do
the same without as many side effects one of your thoughts the nurse said she wouldn't change
doses without a scan in another month away can we argue with her or just do what they say for
waiting for a signature test which is a circulating tumor cell just to come back also are those tests
pretty accurate compared to tumor markers well they're just totally different than tumor markers but
it's just another test to look at things um yeah and fortunately um the the personalized medicine
with your oncologist it's kind of just doesn't exist very often anymore um and it's part it's really honestly
uh probably you know maybe 75% because they are covering their butt as far as a lawsuit
or in 25% that they just are not maybe very ethnical I don't know um but it's it's really
hard to get personalized care where you can say hey can we drop this down a little bit I would just ask
or try to ask and see what they say I mean she might have a valid reason to say no I want to keep
you on this you're doing well it's deal with the symptoms she might have you know kind of give you
a bunch of loading to try to keep you on that to keep her tail covered so she doesn't get in trouble
with her boss it's just the doctors don't control things anymore they're just puns in the whole
grand scheme a big form unfortunately by homocysteine level was high at 15.6 I took methyl B12 right so
person has high homocysteine that's where you have to take some methyl groups either methyl B12 or
methyl folate they have both are methyl donors you have to lower the homocysteine levels did it for
two weeks it had it rechecked it dropped to 12.7 we'll see how fast that is that's remarkable
unbelievable so it went down but it's still a little elevated the integrative doctor was we
to keep taking the methyl B12 to get it done further I took five days off and for the test one
waiting results do you agree that I should keep taking it or should I do it on the course of action
no I agree you should keep taking it get that done further and then you could pulse it and I don't
think you should ever having that level of homocysteine I don't think you should ever go off of it for
good you could like go on two days a week or something like that so maybe you're just going to do that
Saturday and Sunday and and you could be able to keep your homocysteine levels at bay
that way but you could easily do a blood test and make sure you're keeping it at bay but you don't
want it to get elevated like that why because homocysteine etches your interior of your epithelial cells
your walls of your artery arteries your endothelial cells and damaged endothelial cells
what do they do they have these little grooves and they collect cholesterol so and then cholesterol
gets to be the bad name that they're the bad guy causing these cholesterol plaques and your artery
would have really had nothing to do with cholesterol whatsoever it's the damaged endothelial cells
good antibiotics help and come batting by type of cancer so antibiotic use is an off-label
use medication in the caroncology protocols so we've had people do some of those protocols
and for helping with cancer it's really hard to measure the success or not because they're doing
so many other things so it's hard to know maybe other people could chime in that maybe they we're doing
everything and their cancer was going the wrong way and they added some of the off-label drugs in
their cancer turned eroded and started going the right way um they don't remember anybody off the
top of my head that had that experience um but I'm not sure there's maybe a few people have this
call that I've done that the off-label drug use so I don't know as far as your particular cancer
I'm not sure yeah I can't make that comment if that would be true in your case um and uh
using the antibiotics um I don't remember that was one of the things that most of our patients
shine one of the off-label drugs that most of our patients shine away from um because of the damage
to the microbiota that is definitely going to happen when you're doing that our probiotics a better
approach well I don't think that probiotics is a cancer treatment is an approach um probiotics help
your microbiota but it's not really a cancer treatment approach okay so the person it's
asked this question I believe is the person that has an open wound the other thing that
may help with an open wound uh is using uh probiotics topically so um I've had numerous cases where
using a probiotics topically meeting you have a capsule that you open up and it should not be a
spore probiotic so there's uh it should be just a regular probiotic not a spore probiotic if you
know the difference so there's it'll say it right on the uh on the packaging this is probiotic spore
typically we call spore something like i.g. spore or mega spore or something so a done spore probiotic
where you just sprinkle a little bit of the you know an open up a capsule and it's sprinkled
a half the capsule on the wound every day um we've had some pretty cool results with that you
could think about doing that but taking it orally I don't think that's going to have much of an effect
on a cancer of course or less the cancer is like you know in the esophagus or in the
uh you know in the duandil area or something like that what do you think about a rec stump therapy
that is a medication um um I legally can even comment on that so you suggested cutting down a lion's
made this is a latest cheek swab could you please advise why that's just because that's what came up
in the testing uh about a month now I periodically have muscle spasms on my right shoulder
first three weeks it happened while I laid in bed now it just spasms anytime but periodically
could this be linked to the cancer so this person has had a neck cancer and yes it could be
affecting just the the space-occupied lesion of the cancer where the cancer is it could be affected
the brachial plexus that's the nerve plexus that's coming out of the cervical spine and it goes
also backwards to the rhubboids and the trapezius muscles and the um that could definitely be
causing some of the spasms going to the chiropractor getting those work done can be helpful anything
you can do to decrease inflammation could be helpful uh ice using ice hot cold packs could be
helpful using a tens unit could be helpful any anti-inflammatory nutrition could be helpful
are there certain gene variations I should be looking at in my genetic report to see if
glyphosate might be causing a problem in my body or is it just any of the detox related genes
I'm already taking two teaspoons of life was almost glutathione and three tablespoons
of ground tuna per day so the glutathione is going to help both phase one in phase two in the liver
plus it's going to help with interest cellular detoxification of glyphosate
and anything so um what gene variations should you look at the NAT genes the PUN1 genes
um the cytochrome P450 genes it's all your detoxification pathways your um catalyse genes
your superoxide genes are those would be the things that you could think of most people don't have
glyphosate problems because they have solely because they have genetic defects they have glyphosate
problems because they have glyphosate exposure so you could say well why doesn't everybody have
glyphosate problems the answer is everybody probably doesn't glyphosate problems especially in the
United States um had a nice lung conversation with a gal from Germany who's living in the United
States now my daughters were talking to her for quite a while talking about you know all um
of the pesticides and herbicides and things have been banned in Europe so if you could get a
hold of food that's imported you're probably better off i took a glyphosate test since you found
it to be a possible cause what you did by last cheek so i'm a sense that the result was 1.5 which
looks to be in the 50th percentile is this a very bad score um yeah i did look at your test it's
is it a bad score it's there isn't any good score when it comes to glyphosate so let's just leave it
at that how much do you think this could contribute to my breast cancer well remember so what your score
is today doesn't doesn't mean that's what your score was um four years ago when the cancer started
growing why didn't you diagnose till two years ago yeah i said that right your cancer started growing
long before you were diagnosed so your score might have been much higher than you've got a lot of
detox work up to this point and then you just get the test done your score might have been
way worse even six months ago when you took the cheek swab you had already suggested increasing my
clear toxins three per day that on kale support in hm et binder and lymph active from cell core
i'm still doing a coffee at a memory day and a grade so the day time and highest quality
be that can afford you know i don't think there's anything else you have to do based upon the results
of those tests how important is the grounding that in conjunction with the rif treatments so the
grounding bet that comes with your rif machine is to be used when you use the ion pro wave
so the ion pro wave everybody thinks it's just to pull junk out of your body through your feet
no it's to get different frequencies in your body and doing so it does have an avenue of escape
for different things as well so but the purpose of that is to pull the frequencies into your body and
you do want to put the grounding bet behind your back when you're doing ion pro wave
what's the only time you're using the grounding bet if you have a different grounding bet
at home or at the grounding sheet at home as i have said in so many of the videos
that grounding sheets should be used on the lower half of your band underneath the fitted
mattress fitted sheet the lower half of your bed underneath the fitted sheet i got a yeast infection
from staff and antibiotics back in june july i have a limited fruit i take probiotics daily as well as
probiotic and fuse coconut yogurt rectally and vaguely daily i've taken a whole bottle of kittas
and forte i still have very itchy eczema on my eyelids etc etc one of my missing how do i get rid
of these infection so kandida is a very difficult thing to get rid of because the systemic kandida
is just a side of other hill hill too so when you're doing other things like chemotherapy and all this
stuff it's just really really difficult you have to just be patient with yourself
um you're doing all the right things these these probiotic confused yogurt rectally and vaginally
you're just trying to get probiotics at every orifice of your body is what you're trying to do
um and then just you know all the other good things that you are doing this is just a whole lot
more that you could do um we can't be adding more supplements to your protocol you're just on so
many things this way till you get through the chemo then we can discuss possible next steps with
that what do you think about using mistletoe injections and in and in fusion form well i'm all
all for that so the purpose of mistletoe injections is to stimulating immune response
um against the cancer and you can start with an IV mistletoe form that can be beneficial to get
things kickstarted too so of course it has serious cancer and you want to get an immune response
kickstarted that could be very beneficial what are your thoughts on rso rick simsinoil so rick simsinoil
is very very highly concentrated thc from marijuana so rick simsinoil could be very beneficial it comes
in a little syringe tube because it is like tar in its consistency it's very very sticky
if you let it warm up it becomes a little less viscous and you could manage it a little bit better
but you gotta be careful with how much you take if you're going to do rick simsinoil it doesn't
um co-direct anything else you're doing because it's not a oxidizing agent that needs to be taken
you know away from any antioxidants etc like protocell or something so you could do it in conjunction
with anything else you're doing. Matter of fact we've had people do rick simsinoil
conjunction with chemotherapy um now rick simsinoil has to be make sure you source it from is
a most honest source you can find that they're actually um you know yeah it's a it's a clean process
that they're using because in order to extract the thc from the marijuana plant you have to use
some sort of extraction process that usually they're using something like ever clear or even
isopropyl alcohol but then no harm no foul because you're heated it up and burning all of that off
now a person who's making it if you're making it in your backyard you would never make it in your
house because you could blow up your house but if you're making it in your backyard where there's
air flowing through you could choose to take shortcut and to stop the process before all the alcohol or
whatever solvent you use to extract the thc is completely a burned off and then you could actually
you know sell more of it because boy instead of getting eight ounces now I have 12 ounces and I
going to be able to make more money so you want to buy it from somebody who is reputable enough
that cares about what they're making that's going to be highest quality for wherever it's going to
end point consume it because that um solvent that they use to pull the thc out of the marijuana is toxic
you know you could get sick off of that probably that die or anything but you could to make you ill and
the thc concentrated thc of rick simsinoel is going to make you ill and off of it itself because
you know I don't know anybody who's ever done rick simsinoel and said oh this was so pleasant I just
love it so it makes you feel super super loopy you gotta start really slow just doing one great
and rice before bed uh per day and then move up to two and then get up to three and then a true
rick simsinoel approach from rick simsinoel is um doing three grades of rice three times a day and I
know very few people have been able to get up to that level um personally I've never smoked marijuana
before I've never taken drugs I've never done anything like that never hardly ever taken prescription
medication my mom was very natural and how she raised us uh that's where what made me want to do
what I'm doing um but when I was in the worst my cancer I took rick simsinoel and only for
well I only did a couple times because I got so unbelievably loopy I thought I was going crazy I just
couldn't do it I just literally could not do it now I have used thc in liquid form that wasn't
nearly the concentration of rick simsinoel and even that um I didn't it didn't do well um so it's uh
I actually used thc um the other day because my body was just I was hurting so bad I worked too hard
in the garden and I just felt like things flared up but I could have flared up some um
history and um I did some rick simsinoel to because I don't like taking drugs I don't like even taking
time and all or anything and I was so unbelievably loopy the next day I just I just I don't know
I just have an intolerance to anything so um but not against it we've seen people have great results
and I just say really be careful and go slow I get two chemo and one immunotherapy IV every three
weeks after the first two infusions the tumors are shrinking daily and it's amazing right however
I just had my third IV last Thursday I'm not silly seeing or feeling the same positive changes
as chemo just stopped working at some point well the answer is more complex than that the answer
can be yes the chemo can stop working but number two remember if you get so much shrinkage it doesn't
mean the chemo it's just gonna keep going it's gonna disappear because so maybe the cells that
we're growing are dead and now the cells that remain are not reproducing this is my disagreement
with oncologists you know they just think oh no we're out to finish the protocol why because that's
the protocol well who made the protocol oh yours of research that's a bunch of baloney you know
made the protocol the drum company made the protocol that's who made the protocol um so this is my
argument this is why I always say don't don't be scared of doing chemo or immunotherapy you could stop
at any time not telling you to stop but you're gonna consider that uh maybe I should pause I don't
gonna pray about that because it did what it was supposed to do and now you're gonna take over for
here I don't know so there's pros and cons to everything so really pray about that I don't have
an answer for that I'm very tired having COVID any suggestions to help me build back my COVID my fatigue up
well one thing that can be very good for uh post COVID fatigue is the clear talks okay pulling
that out of there the lumbar- lumbar- lumbar kinase in the nano kinase can be very helpful for that
increasing blood circulation with a product like that and garlic and things like that can be very helpful
Oxaloacetate has been found to be extremely helpful for post-COVID fatigue. Oxaloacetate is a
solid product called betagene and a product called oxaloacetate CFS for chronic fatigue syndrome.
So, he tried the much lesser form as far as dosage called betagene first, much less expensive too,
and I would give that a shot. We've had some people with really good results with that.
Matter of fact, this oxaloacetate, I actually do an interview
with a little bit who owns that company, did an interview a year ago with him. I've been using
betagene since it first came out years and years ago. It has been proven to decrease tumors.
We have a number of our patients on betagene, slashoac, oxaloacetate for that.
Really good for brain tumors. First came out with a study with aftercytoma and glioblastoma,
and then it now has been proven with breast cancer and other cancers too.
I've been on Novoluluble, immunotherapy, furbizotheliala for about two and a half years.
Drug company recommends no more than two years when we cross the tier year bark by liver
numbers started to rise. Last month my college is halted the treatment because the liver numbers were
high. I don't know if it was because they had to live it at two years because of that reason,
because it started to negatively affect the liver or not. But on the prednisone yesterday to try
to bring those numbers down, any suggestions, yeah, I would suggest you need liver support.
So if there's damage to the liver from a drug, you need to, number one,
do everything you can, everything you know to help increase the detoxification of the liver,
one of those hot packs of the liver, confianabas, cancer opaks of the liver. All your liver support
supplements, running the liver program in the normalizing frequency folder of the rife machine,
using ion protein, doing sodas. And if you're like doing all those, what else could I possibly do?
Another great help to rebuild the liver is liver tissue. So I mentioned this a few weeks ago,
decides for health has a new product called organ synergy, organ synergy. It's in capsule form and
it's in powder form. It just came up with a capsule form, so we don't have that on the store. Yeah,
but the powder form we have on the store and it has organ tissue liver and some other organs all from
bovine, sourced, New England, clean, sourced animals. And that could be really helpful to help build
back the liver, which you need to really support those detoxification pathways.
Every way you know how every way that we've talked about, look at the detoxification course as well.
And mainly the phase one and phase two and phase three section of that course. And
and then think about supporting the liver, building back with with organ tissue.
At many lumps in my neck and growing, I requested an ultrasound to make sure none of them are blood
clots after skating by arms and legs. I was told there are no clots, but all our swollen lymph nodes,
since I do have cancer in my lymph, would these all possibly probably be cancerous? Should I be
addressing those lymph nodes, helping them drain, heal, etc. Yeah, they could be cancerous. Sure. So
what's how do you know the difference to a swollen lymph node or a cancerous lymph node? Well,
the the only perfect way to know is to do a biopsy, but there's some hints. So a swollen lymph node
typically will be more squishy. A cancerous lymph node is going to be or hard like a marble.
So that's just one hint. Should I do lymphatic drainage? Should I do things? Well, everything is
you're already doing. I would not do lymphatic massage. In this case, I wouldn't do you know,
there's nothing else I would do except exercise, emotion and sona and everything else you're doing,
supporting downstream from the lymph system, which is supporting the blood, supporting the
the liver and that's phase one, two, three, four, five, six. Making sure your bowel movements are
going well and making sure you're doing coffee animals. In the uncle type score, something I should
pay attention to is the uncle type score, something I should pay attention to. Yes, it could give you some
clarity of whether you should do chemo or not. So if you had a score of, you know, a really high
score that would tell you that maybe maybe chemo should be in your car in the car. If it's a really
relatively low score, then that would kind of confirm that you don't want to do chemo. So that's
the only way I would use it. I asked the oncologist, they're supposed to be looking at 21 genes,
specific to tumors, then why doesn't it tell me what they found seems a bit sketchy to me.
It's a newer test that came out a couple of years ago and it's just how well you'll do with chemo.
So I don't actually understand that complete physics of the test itself. So I can't really comment on that.
I have my gallbladder, no gallstones. So just because you don't have no gallstones, it doesn't
mean that you don't have sluggish gallbladder. So also consider that. And then
so I do, if you want to try the liquid, you don't pay for it because I have cells that is
near expression that I'll give you. So let's throw that in and it's good for another
five years after that, but we can't sell it. So I have a bunch of that that I forget right now.
Since my third chemo last week had pains that come and go in my ovary regions like menstrual
cramps, but I'm not menstruated in a year to half. Could this be from the coffee
enemas or from the vaginal yogurt infusions or an autoimmune issue beginning from the immunotherapy
or other ideas. I mean, there's just no way that anybody could make that call
with just the code that you have pain in your ovary regions. It could be some different things.
So I just I don't know. I mean, again, would you run some labs to see if you have antibodies to
you know, ovary tissue or I wouldn't even do that when you're still doing chemo therapy. You got
to let your body calm down before you even run any of those kind of labs. Additionally, I have
bumpy itchy head, chemo rash. So yeah, when you're the one who asked the question about the yeast
infections, I mean, you could also be some of the itchies and rashes. All this could be just
negative effects of the chemo therapy and you detox the chemo therapy as well. So
before you make another diagnosis, you got to get through this piece. You got to kind of take
steps at a time. Yeah, you want to try to treat the symptoms well. So you're not miserable going
through this, but all these can be causes of the drugs that you're putting in your body.
My doctor who offers the phytonidetic therapy says it's laser level four. He's good friends with
Dr. Calfeld. So he knows about Calfeld's way to do PDT. So I think Dr. Calfeld's way that he does the
PDT is the correct way. I think just using the level four laser is not phytonidemic therapy in my
definition. So he wants me to take methylene blue and riboflabe of two hours prior to the procedure.
I don't know what color laser he uses. The color makes no difference. It would be a laser light going
through into my bloodstream, but I don't know what's in the IV bag. Unless it's like super expensive,
there's I don't think it's any harm in trying that. But I would also ask the doctor if there's any
benefit, if you're only thinking of doing one or two sessions, there may not be very many benefits
and doing one or two sessions either. So you might have to ask the doctor, you know what to
mean about a session to see some benefit would be. My mercury fillings were all removed a few years ago,
being drilled out with no safety precautions by a traditional dentist. I had an appointment with my
biological dentist last week. I still have two crows at show metal underneath the white caps. My
bio dentist said they were mixture of metals, but not mercury. He was not concerned about them.
What are your thoughts? Well, I would default to the biological dentist if he knows that they're not
mercury. I forget you if you check for metal toxicity. Is it safe to oil pull? If the metal is
underneath the caps, that yes, it's okay to oil pull. I met with an integrative doctor today about
addressing my toxic mold issues. She has a whole protocol of detox I need to go through and she
wants me to pause some of the supplements I'm taking from you until we have this done. She's concerned
that it will be too much to keep taking everything. Is it best to contact Megan and put a pause on certain
supplements. Tell her done with the mold detox. Okay, so I don't remember seeing a microtox test.
I don't remember if I went over a microtox test with you or not.
But I'm assuming that that's what you're talking about with a more toxic mold issues because let's
make sure we're defining our terms. I know sometimes doctors simplify and maybe I overcomplicate so
I apologize. But I think clarity is important. So a lot of doctors say you have toxic mold issues.
That's what we need to detox. Nobody has molded their body. So if you so a microtox test is testing for
what are called microtoxins, which are toxins that mold produces. So exposure to molds produce these
chemicals called microtoxins. They're not molds. They're chemicals. So if you show elevated microtoxins
on a microtox test, the first thing that you need to do is to make sure you're not. You don't have any
current exposure or any detoxification that you do will be for not. Zero nothing. You have to make
sure you address current exposure. So if you have current exposure, black mold, or aspergillus, or
any of the molds that are listed on that test that produce these different microtoxins,
no business trying to do any detox. So that's number one. Then number two, then you start pulling
these microtoxins out. It's not a simple procedure that you're going to reduce these in 90 days by
just taking some some different medications or some different pills. So beware of that too. So
you need objective testing. So they better do a post microtox test to look at evaluate that.
So if that's what this doctor is doing, and then that's your choice than you by all means,
you can do that. But if they're for some reason, say that it just concerned me about that term that
you use, maybe it's just a term you use there. But I've heard that before where people go, I went
to this doctor and they said, I have I mold toxicity and I have to do this because I have to get
killed this mold in my body. That's that's just not right. So so I apologize for explain it. I
might have not have anything to do with you or what your doctors do. It might be fantastic, but
just want to clarify that for other people. As people do the microtox test that they think they
have molded their body and it's they have microtoxins in their body, throb molds that they've been exposed
to. So that's what you want to get rid of. Should I continue with the kendison forte for my
recent infection? I have very low body for it. I would say no, wait on it until after you're done with
your chemo and immunotherapy. Why is chemo given systemically and not directly injected into the tumors?
Because they're treating your whole body and I don't know of any chemos that are directly
injected into the tumors. Doc emailed back. It will be a fiber optic through. Okay, so that's good.
So the fiber optic that's good. So I would but the next question I would ask you is just what I said is
to do the to ask them what how many treatments do you think it should be? I did have the microtoxic
test. You have a copy. Okay, I'll look at that too. I do plan to check the house and make sure
not get any additional exposure, especially somebody like you there because you you've been doing so much
detox over time and if your levels are still very elevated my concern would be you have current exposure
or recent exposure. So somebody that you okay has been doing any any detoxification has been living
to average American life and got sick and other going through some sicknesses and you do a microtox
test and it's elevated. Well, that could have been from an exposure multiple years ago.
Right, but for somebody who's done so much work on detoxification, I guess you could say well,
it could have been much higher elevated, you know, a year ago, and that is true too. So but you do
want to just rule out current exposure, just make sure. All right, and you know for everybody who's
looking at mold as an issue, I do have go to our blog post and type in mold and you'll see I did
an interview with a great company that does mold testing where you they said you little petri dishes
that you do that they're really a good company and they're fairly inexpensive. So look at that.
How do I get HCl and from where do I get this? The HCl that I would recommend is a product called
Clear Digest, Clear Digest, that's our product. It would only take any HCl product if you only take
with your meals. You don't take HCl and an empty stomach ever. Any product that has HCl and you
don't take an empty stomach, Clear Digest is the product. Okay, with that, I think we will say goodbye.
I pray for all of you and we'll see you guys next week.